There are people who drive us crazy at our jobs, but science hasn't given that particular problem a lot of thought. Recently, a guy named Will Felps may have made some small progress in this area. He wanted to figure out if one person in the workplace can ruin a workplace. Not just disrupt the way that people get along and fill coworkers with weird feelings and uncomfortable moments that they think about for hours afterwards, but could one person actually lower productivity? Does one bad apple spoil the whole bunch?
工作中有时会遇到让人抓狂的人，但科学界对此类特定问题并没有进行过深入的研究。最近，一位名叫威尔·费尔普斯（Will Felps）的人在这方面取得了一些微小的进展。他想弄清楚职场中是否真有一个人就能毁掉整个工作环境。这不仅是指破坏人际关系，让同事产生各种奇怪的感觉和不适，以至于事后要反思几个小时；他是想问，一个人是否真的能降低生产力？一颗坏苹果是否真的会坏了一锅汤？
First off can I maybe just describe a little bit what kind of behaviors count as bad apple behaviors?
首先，我能否先描述一下什么样的行为属于“坏苹果”行为？
This is Will Felps. I reached him on the phone in the Netherlands, where these days he is an assistant professor of management at the Rotterdam School of Management. But back when he was in grad school doing this research, he read all the relevant studies on teamwork and group dynamics looking for clues about bad apple behavior. And he didn't find much. But he did find-- buried in correlation tables and footnotes-- three personality types, three kinds of behavior that seem to hurt group dynamics and group performance in a bad apple sort of way.
这就是威尔·费尔普斯。我在荷兰通过电话采访了他，如今他在鹿特丹管理学院担任管理学助理教授。但在他读研究生进行这项研究时，他查阅了所有关于团队合作和群体动力的相关研究，试图寻找关于“坏苹果”行为的线索。他并没有发现太多，但他确实在相关性表格和脚注中发现了三种性格类型，这三种行为似乎会以一种“坏苹果”的方式损害群体动力和群体绩效。
And these three sets of behaviors are-- well in layman's terms, you say someone who is a real jerk, who attacks or insults others, someone who is a slacker, who does less than they can, and then finally someone who is a depressive pessimist. So if you have a team member or an office-mate who's a real jerk, slacker or depressive pessimist, there's a chance-- and actually maybe a fairly good chance-- that they might spoil the barrel. And so what we do in the laboratory is that we create bad apples in the laboratory and see what effects they have. We create these by hiring confederates.
这三组行为用通俗的话说就是：一个真正的混蛋，他会攻击或侮辱他人；一个懒鬼，他会尽可能地偷懒；最后是一个消极的悲观主义者。所以，如果你的团队成员或办公室同事是个混蛋、懒鬼或消极的悲观主义者，那么很有可能——实际上可能是相当大的可能——他们会坏了一锅汤。因此，我们在实验室里所做的，就是人为制造“坏苹果”来观察其产生的影响。我们通过雇佣“托儿”来实现这一点。
Now you're saying confederate. You mean you hire an actor?
你说“托儿”，是指你雇了一名演员吗？
Exactly. Yeah, so we hire an actor. And in particular, what I did is I just advertised for someone who was willing to participate in experiments and maybe display negative behavior. And I got a number of people who auditioned. There were maybe 12 people who showed up. And there was one guy who was head and shoulders better than everybody else.
正是如此。我们雇了一名演员。特别是我当时只是发布了招聘启事，寻找愿意参加实验并表现出消极行为的人。有大约12个人来试镜，其中有一个人表现得比其他所有人都出色得多。
The actor was a college student named Nick [? Fascitelli ?]. And once Will had him, he started his experiment. It went like this. He got college students and put them into teams of four. That would be three undergraduates, plus the actor who was undercover. The other undergrads didn't know that he was an actor in cahoots with the researchers. Will gave all the groups the same task to do. It was an exercise where they made some basic management decisions. And Will told them that they would be scored, and there would be a prize of $100 per person for the group that did the best. So they were motivated to do well.
这名演员是一位名叫尼克·法西泰利的大学生。一旦确定人选，威尔就开始了他的实验。实验过程是这样的：他找来大学生，将他们分成四人一组。每组由三名本科生加上那名卧底演员组成。其他本科生并不知道他是与研究人员串通好的演员。威尔给所有小组布置了相同的任务。这是一个进行基本管理决策的练习。威尔告诉他们，实验会有评分，表现最好的小组每人会获得100美元的奖金。因此，他们都有动力去完成好任务。
They would work together for maybe about 45 minutes on this task. We would videotape this. And this actor, Nick, he would display one of three types of bad apple behavior. He'd either be a jerk, a slacker or a depressive pessimist. And first the jerk behavior, right? What we did was someone would make a comment, and he would say, "Are you kidding me?" He would also make comments like, "Have you actually taken a business course before?" to embarrass them or insult them.
他们在一起工作大约45分钟来完成这项任务，我们全程录像。演员尼克会表现出三种“坏苹果”行为中的一种。他要么是个混蛋，要么是个懒鬼，要么是个消极的悲观主义者。首先是“混蛋”行为，当有人发表评论时，他会说：“你在开玩笑吗？”他还会说一些诸如“你以前真的修过商业课程吗？”之类的话来羞辱或打击他们。
How would he do slacker?
他如何表现得像个懒鬼？
Well one, he would lean back in his chair, maybe put his feet up on the desk, and then he would start text messaging a friend on his cellphone. And sometime during the experiment he would pull out a meal. So he would pull out a sandwich and a Coke.
其中一点，他会向后倚在椅子上，甚至把脚放在桌子上，然后开始用手机给朋友发短信。在实验期间，他还会拿出一份餐点，比如三明治和可乐。
And then how did he do depressive?
那他如何表现得像个消极的悲观主义者？
Yeah, in that case, what he would is-- in some ways--
在那种情况下，他会——在某种程度上——
Because I have got to say, he has only got 45 minutes. You know what I mean? It's a small palette with which to communicate depressive.
因为我得说，他只有45分钟的时间。你明白我的意思吗？用来传达“消极悲观”的手段非常有限。
It was challenging for him. And he would put his head down on the table, and just look like-- I don't know-- his cat had died. That was what he said was his mental inspiration.
这对他来说确实是个挑战。他会把头埋在桌子上，看起来就像——我不知道——就像他的猫死了一样。他说这就是他的心理灵感来源。
The scripts that the actor used are included in Appendix A of Will's study. And they specify that the depressive pessimist will complain that the task that they're doing is unenjoyable and make statements doubting the group's ability to succeed. That the jerk will state that other people's ideas are not adequate, but will offer no alternatives, himself. And he'll say, you guys need to listen to the expert, me. That the slacker character will say, whatever and I really don't care.
演员所使用的剧本包含在威尔研究的附录A中。剧本规定，消极的悲观主义者会抱怨任务乏味，并发表质疑团队成功能力的言论；混蛋会声称别人的想法不够好，但他自己却不提出任何替代方案，还会说“你们这些人需要听听专家的，也就是我”；懒鬼角色则会说“随便吧，我根本不在乎”。
Now the conventional wisdom in the research on this kind of thing is that none of this should have had much effect on the group at all. Groups are powerful. Group dynamics are powerful. And so groups dominate individuals, not the other way around. There is tons of research going back decades demonstrating that people conform to group values and norms. But Will found the opposite.
针对这类问题的传统研究观点是，这些行为根本不应该对团队产生太大影响。团队的力量是强大的，群体动力的力量是强大的，所以群体会主导个人，而不是相反。几十年来有大量的研究证明人们会顺从群体的价值观和规范。但威尔却发现了相反的结果。
Invariably, the groups that had this actor Nick behaving in these ways would perform worse. And this despite the fact that there were in some groups people who were very talented, very smart, very likable.
毫无例外，有演员尼克以这些方式行事的团队表现得更差。即便有些团队里有非常有才华、非常聪明且非常讨人喜欢的人，结果依然如此。
In fact, the actor's behavior had a profound effect. In dozens of trials, over and over, when he acted like a bad apple with a group, that group would perform 30% to 40% worse than groups without a bad apple. And even more surprising to Will was how dramatic the effect was on the way people in the groups treated each other.
事实上，这名演员的行为产生了深远的影响。在数十次试验中，一次又一次，当他扮演“坏苹果”时，该团队的表现会比没有“坏苹果”的团队差30%到40%。而更让威尔吃惊的是，这种行为对小组成员间相互对待方式的影响是多么剧烈。
People would argue and fight. And they would not share their relevant information. They would communicate less when he was really any of these types of bad apples. But what was eerily surprising was how these team members would start to take on his characteristics. So for example, remember we videotaped all of these. And you would see that people would start-- well, so when he was a jerk, they would be a jerk too. So they would start being a little bit insulting, or abrasive, or obnoxious. And what was really interesting is they wouldn't just do it in response to him, but also to each other. So there's a spillover effect.
人们会争吵和打架，并且不再分享相关信息。当他表现出任何一种“坏苹果”行为时，沟通都会减少。最让人毛骨悚然且感到惊讶的是，这些团队成员开始沾染上他的特征。例如，还记得我们记录了所有这些过程吗？你会发现人们开始——比如当他是个混蛋时，他们也变得像个混蛋。他们开始变得有点侮辱人、生硬或令人厌烦。有趣的是，他们不仅是对他，甚至彼此之间也开始这样。所以这产生了一种溢出效应。
When Nick acted like a slacker, the spillover effect would kick in. And eventually someone else in the group would declare that the task they'd been given just wasn't important.
当尼克扮演懒鬼时，溢出效应就会发生。最终，组里的其他人也会宣称他们所做的任务根本不重要。
Someone would eventually say, let's just get this over with. Let's just fill in some responses and get out of here. And they would just mark down anything and then give up. What was maybe the most interesting and surprising was with the depressive pessimist. I remember watching this video where you start out, all the members are sitting up straight, energized, very excited to take on this potentially interesting and challenging task. And then by the end, they are, like him, all with their heads on the desk. So they have-- which is very strange. You're not used to seeing a group of people who are sprawled out on the desk as they do any kind of a job or a task.
最终有人会说：“咱们快点结束吧，随便填点东西然后走人。”他们会胡乱填写然后放弃。最有趣且最让人惊讶的或许是关于消极悲观主义者的那一组。我记得看这段视频时，开始时所有成员都坐得笔直、充满活力，对这个看似有趣且具有挑战性的任务感到兴奋。但到最后，他们就像他一样，全把头埋在桌子上。这种现象非常奇怪，你并不习惯看到一群人做任务时全都趴在桌上。
Well it's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show we have stories of bad apples and people who are accused of being bad apples. Like for example, one family who refused to vaccinate their kids from measles, and then that led to a measles outbreak with quarantines and lots of other kids getting sick. Comedian Mike Birbiglia explains in our show today how he personally, single-handedly ruined a charity fundraiser. And Nancy Updike tells the story of a special place, a magical place, a place where no one is allowed to ruin things for anyone else.
大家好，这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》节目，由公共广播国际台发行，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目中我们讲述关于“坏苹果”以及被指控为“坏苹果”的人的故事。例如，有一个家庭拒绝为他们的孩子接种麻疹疫苗，这导致了一场麻疹爆发，随之而来的是隔离措施和许多其他孩子患病。今天节目中，喜剧演员麦克·伯比利亚将解释他如何单枪匹马地搞砸了一场慈善筹款活动。南希·厄普代克将讲述一个特殊地方的故事——一个神奇的地方，那里的人不允许任何人搞砸事情。
Because in this last week as we've been putting together this show, I've really been struck at how common bad apples are. Truthfully, I've been haunted by my conversation with Will Felps. Hearing about his research, you realize just how easy it is to poison any group. Will Felps told me about this study that somebody did looking at all kinds of industries and businesses. And what they found is that the best predictor of how any team performs is not how great the best member is or what the average member of the group is like. It all comes down to what your worst team member is like. The teams with the worst person at the bottom, those teams perform the poorest. That's harsh.
因为在过去这一周制作节目的过程中，我真正被“坏苹果”的普遍程度所震撼。说实话，我一直被我和威尔·费尔普斯的谈话所困扰。听了他的研究，你会意识到毒害一个群体是多么容易。威尔·费尔普斯告诉我一项研究，有人调查了各行各业和企业，结果发现预测团队表现的最佳指标，并不是成员中有多么优秀的人，也不是群体平均水平如何，而完全取决于团队中最差的那名成员是什么样。团队中最差的那个人决定了整个团队表现得有多糟糕。这太残酷了。
And I, and I have got to say everybody in our office who's heard Will's interview-- we were talking about this earlier today. Each of us has had moments this past week where we, individually, by ourselves have wondered, am I doing bad apple stuff? Am I the bad apple unwittingly? And when I talked to Will about this, I asked him if he found himself doing this as well in his own workplace. Here's his response.
我必须说，我们办公室所有听过威尔采访的人——我们今天早些时候还在谈论这个。过去一周，我们每个人都曾有那么一瞬间私下自问：我有没有表现出“坏苹果”的行为？我是不是在不知不觉中成了“坏苹果”？当我与威尔谈及此事时，我问他是否在自己的工作中也发现了这种情况，以下是他的回应。
Yes. Yes, I have become very sensitive to this type of behavior. I catch myself sometimes. I'm just very worried now about my effect on other people. I have to say I used to tease a lot more. I used to poke fun at people and their tendencies a lot more than I do now. I thought this was fun, this was building camaraderie, that this was something that they appreciated. But what was interesting is, for example, watching these experiments with this actor, people would, for example, even laugh at his jokes when he was making fun of someone else. They would all laugh. But then afterwards, for example, when they would rate whether or not they would be willing to work on his team again, they would say, definitely not, I hated this. It was having a really negative impact. And I guess that rubbed off on me. So I just stopped being, I don't know, I stopped teasing so much.
是的，我已经对这类行为变得非常敏感。有时我也会发觉自己有这样的行为。我现在非常担心我对别人的影响。我必须说，我以前很喜欢开玩笑，比现在更喜欢嘲笑别人的倾向。我曾经以为这很有趣，是在建立友谊，是别人所欣赏的行为。但有趣的是，例如观察这些有演员参与的实验时，人们甚至会在他取笑别人时跟着笑。他们都会笑，但事后当他们评价是否愿意再次与他共事时，他们会说：“绝对不，我讨厌这样。”这产生了非常负面的影响。我想这也影响到了我，所以我只是不再那样开玩笑了。
Now of course this is just one study in the laboratory. As Will points out, group dynamics in the real world-- where people work together for more than 45 minutes-- may be different in some ways yet to be studied. Though Will did see one glimmer of hope in his research. It was in one group in the study. It was the most surprising thing that happened during this research, something that completely caught Will off guard.
当然，这只是实验室里的一项研究。正如威尔所指出的，现实世界中的群体动力——人们在一起工作的时间远超45分钟——在某些方面可能与实验室中不同，还有待进一步研究。不过，威尔在研究中确实看到了一丝希望，这出现在研究中的某一个小组里。这是研究过程中发生的最令人惊讶的事情，完全出乎威尔的意料。
There was one group where the bad apple didn't spoil the barrel. There was one group that performed really well.
有一个小组，“坏苹果”并没有坏了一锅汤。有一个小组表现得非常好。
And what was that group doing?
那个小组做了什么？
There was just one guy who was a particularly good leader. And what he would do is he would ask questions. And he would engage all the team members and defuse conflicts. And I found out later that he is actually the son of a diplomat. So his father, I guess, is a diplomat from some South American country. And he had this amazing diplomatic ability to defuse the conflict that normally would emerge when this actor, Nick, would display all this real jerk behavior.
组里有一个人是一位特别出色的领导者。他会提出问题，让所有团队成员参与进来，并化解冲突。我后来发现，他实际上是一位外交官的儿子。所以我想，他的父亲可能是来自南美某个国家的外交官。他有一种非凡的外交能力，可以化解当演员尼克表现出混蛋行为时通常会出现的冲突。
Seeing this diplomat's son do his thing has led Will to his next research project, which is about whether a group leader can change the dynamics and performance of a group simply by going around and asking questions, soliciting everyone's opinions, making sure everybody is heard. If that is true, if listening is all that it takes to overcome bad behavior, if listening is more powerful than meanness, sloth, or depression, it's like a trick from a children's story, a golden rule lesson that seems way too after-school special to possibly be true. That by listening to each other, trying to understand each other, we can get to the point where nobody can ruin things for everyone else.
看到这位外交官的儿子大显身手，引导威尔开始了下一个研究项目：探讨群体领导者是否可以通过提问、征求每个人的意见、确保每个人都被倾听，从而改变群体的动态和表现。如果这是真的，如果倾听就是克服不良行为所需的全部，如果倾听比刻薄、懒惰或抑郁更强大，那就像是童话故事里的戏法，一个“黄金法则”的教训，听起来太像校园道德课了，简直让人不敢相信是真的。即通过倾听彼此，尝试理解彼此，我们可以达到一种状态，让任何人都没有机会搞砸大家的事情。
[MUSIC - "ONE BAD APPLE" BY THE JACKSON 5]
[音乐 - 杰克逊五人组的《一颗坏苹果》]
Act One, Shots in the Dark. OK, here's a situation where one family has the chance to ruin things for a lot of people. It's when they decide whether or not to vaccinate their kids. As you've probably heard, there's a whole movement of parents who do not vaccinate because they're scared of the vaccines. This is not just in the United States but all over the world. There are books. People tell their stories on daytime TV. The issue from people who believe in vaccines is that unvaccinated kids put everybody in danger. Diseases like measles-- which for all practical purposes were eradicated in the United States-- now can get a foothold because so many children in some communities are unvaccinated.
第一幕：盲目射击。这是一个关于一个家庭可能毁掉许多人事情的案例。这发生在他们决定是否为孩子接种疫苗的时候。正如你可能听说的那样，有一整群家长因为害怕疫苗而拒绝接种。这种情况不仅在美国，全世界都存在。有相关的书籍，人们在电视上讲述他们的故事。疫苗支持者认为，未接种疫苗的孩子会使所有人处于危险之中。像麻疹这类疾病——实际上在美国几乎已被根除——现在因为一些社区有太多儿童未接种疫苗而得以卷土重来。
This is a touchy, divisive and bitter debate. But at least it's usually pretty abstract. It's people arguing over what might happen some day, because outbreaks of these diseases are so rare. But last winter, 12 kids came down with measles in San Diego. And it all started with a child whose parents had decided not to vaccinate him. Susan Burton tell what happened.
这是一个敏感、分裂且尖锐的辩论。但至少它通常相当抽象，人们在为可能会发生的事情争论，因为这些疾病的爆发非常罕见。但去年冬天，圣迭戈有12名儿童患上了麻疹。这一切始于一个父母决定不给他接种疫苗的孩子。苏珊·伯顿将讲述发生的事情。
The measles came from Switzerland. A seven year old San Diego boy caught the measles there during a family trip. He flew home to the States without any symptoms. And by the time he got sick, and doctors figured out what it was, the boy had already exposed other children. And the outbreak had begun.
麻疹来自瑞士。一名七岁的圣迭戈男孩在家庭旅行中在那里感染了麻疹。他回家时没有任何症状。等他生病并且医生弄清楚是什么病时，男孩已经接触了其他孩子。疫情就这样开始了。
A health warning for parents. A new cluster of measles cases at a San Diego school.
给家长们的健康警告：圣迭戈一所学校出现新的麻疹病例群。
Already the potentially deadly disease has spread to 11 unimmunized children. Three cases are still pending. And another 60 people are in quarantine. Health officials also caution anyone who was at this Trader Joe's in Hillcrest on February 3 or at Whole Foods Market in Hillcrest on January 29 during the two hour window that the disease was in the air.
这种潜在致命的疾病已经传染给11名未免疫的儿童。另有3例待定，还有60人被隔离。卫生官员还提醒任何在2月3日到过希尔克雷斯特的乔氏超市，或在1月29日到过希尔克雷斯特的全食超市，且正好处于疾病传播两小时窗口期内的人。
Every day there were new locations-- Chuck E. Cheese's, a pediatrician's office, a swim school for babies. One child exposed a plane-load of football fans on their way to the NFL Pro Bowl in Hawaii. Meanwhile, the local news was giving everyone a panicky crash course in the disease.
每天都有新的地点——查克奶酪比萨餐厅、儿科诊所、婴儿游泳学校。一个孩子在前往夏威夷观看职业碗橄榄球赛的途中，传染了一飞机的人。与此同时，当地新闻向每个人提供了关于这种疾病的恐慌性速成课程。
If you are not immunized, and you're this close to an infected child, there's a good chance you can catch the measles. But even 50 feet away, you can still contract the disease. In fact, up to 100 feet away and you're still at risk of catching the measles.
如果你没有免疫，而且离感染的孩子这么近，很有可能会患上麻疹。即使距离50英尺远，你仍然可能感染。事实上，距离100英尺以内你都有感染麻疹的风险。
Measles is like a disease in a horror movie. It's one of the most contagious diseases known to mankind. It lingers in the air for two hours after a person with it has left the room. The rash makes a person look like they've grown a whole new red skin. Measles can be fatal.
麻疹就像恐怖电影里的疾病。它是人类已知传染性最强的疾病之一。患者离开房间后，病毒仍会在空气中残留两小时。皮疹会让人的皮肤看起来像是长了一层崭新的红色表皮。麻疹可能是致命的。
And so the San Diego County Health Department immediately launched into detective work on a massive scale. They had to reconstruct the tiniest details of toddlers' lives. Who had been at what birthday party or at whose house for a play date. There were 980 exposures they had to investigate, including 160 from the plane to Hawaii, where the infected child from the flight was now being kept in isolation on a military base. The people at risk were mainly unvaccinated children, either those whose parents had opted out of the shot or babies who were too young to get the shot. It's usually given when kids turn one.
因此，圣迭戈县卫生局立即展开了大规模的侦查工作。他们必须重建幼儿生活的每一个微小细节，谁去过谁的生日派对，或者去谁家玩过。他们必须调查980个接触点，包括160名来自前往夏威夷那架飞机上的乘客，那位感染的男孩现在被隔离在军事基地里。处于风险中的人主要是未接种疫苗的儿童，要么是父母选择不接种的，要么是太小还不能接种疫苗的婴儿。通常孩子满一岁时才会接种。
To stop the measles from spreading, the health officials decided to do something old fashioned, something that's rarely used anymore in this country. They instituted a quarantine. And this is the story of what that meant for that community of parents, about what happened when the actions of one family suddenly had a huge effect on dozens of other families and children. Hilary Chambers' daughter, Finlee, had just turned one when she was quarantined.
为了阻止麻疹传播，卫生官员决定采取一种老派的做法，一种在这个国家已经很少使用的措施：强制隔离。这就是该社区家长们所经历的故事，关于一个家庭的行为如何突然对几十个其他家庭和孩子产生巨大影响的故事。希拉里·钱伯斯的女儿芬莉刚满一岁时就被隔离了。
I was really angry. And I felt like it impacted families financially, emotionally, on so many different levels. So I was mad, and wanted to know how did this happen. And so I did talk to friends. And I have a friend named Paige, who's one of those people that's just totally connected and knows everyone. And so she would-- and her kids weren't even involved in the quarantine. But she would call me and say, OK, so this is what I heard. It was this family was at this place, and then--
我当时非常生气。我觉得这在经济、情感等多个层面影响了家庭。所以我很愤怒，想知道这是怎么发生的。于是我问了朋友。我有个朋友叫佩奇，她是个交际广泛、认识所有人的人。她的孩子甚至没有被隔离，但她会打电话给我说：“好，这是我听到的消息，是那个家庭在某某地方，然后……”
Here's how one year old Finlee ended up in the quarantine. Hilary took her to daycare on a Monday morning. And one of the teachers asked, very sweetly, if Finlee had been vaccinated for measles yet. When Hilary said no, she was sent to the daycare office with Finlee in her arms. The room was packed with people. There was all kinds of commotion. And a woman from the Health Department standing there with a clipboard.
这就是一岁的芬莉最终被隔离的过程。周一早上，希拉里送她去日托中心。其中一位老师非常亲切地问芬莉是否接种了麻疹疫苗。当希拉里说没有时，她抱着芬莉被送到了日托办公室。房间里挤满了人，一片混乱，卫生部门的一名女性手里拿着剪贴板站在那里。
I walked up to her and was like, what's going on? And she said, you guys can't be here right now. And I said, OK, if I take her to the doctor and get her shot today, can I bring her back tomorrow? And she said, "She is not to leave your property for the next three weeks." And my first reaction-- I laughed out loud. And I asked her if she could babysit, because it was either that or freak out, which is what I did next. I mean it was so sudden. And I was scared. And also, what was I going to do for the next three weeks? My husband and I both work. And there were people everywhere, and my daughter, and I have to be at work in an hour.
我走过去问：“发生了什么？”她说：“你们现在不能待在这里。”我说：“好吧，如果我今天带她去看医生打针，明天能带她回来吗？”她说：“接下来的三周内，她不能离开你们的房产范围。”我第一反应是放声大笑。我问她能不能帮忙看孩子，因为要么这样，要么就会崩溃——这确实是我接下来做的事。我的意思是太突然了。我很害怕，而且我接下来三周该怎么办？我和丈夫都要工作。到处都是人，还有我的女儿，我一小时后还要去上班。
At first Hilary was scared Finlee was going to come down with measles. But she didn't. And after a few days, quarantine wasn't frightening, just tedious. Hilary and Finlee would play downstairs, and then to shake things up they would go upstairs. She got regular calls from the Health Department. Someone checked every other day to make sure Hilary was keeping Finlee quarantined. It was like being under surveillance. She even felt weird taking Finlee outside to blow bubbles in the driveway, like someone would know.
起初希拉里很担心芬莉会患上麻疹，但她没有。过了几天，隔离就不再令人恐惧，只是枯燥乏味。希拉里和芬莉会在楼下玩，为了换换环境，他们会去楼上。她会定期接到卫生部门的电话，有人每隔一天检查一次，确保希拉里在执行隔离。这就像处于被监视状态。她甚至觉得带芬莉去车道上吹泡泡都觉得怪怪的，好像会有人知道一样。
Being cooped up during an epidemic used to be a typical part of motherhood. There's an argument that vaccines have actually made it possible for women to work. Hilary is a radio DJ. And during the outbreak she and her husband tag-teamed.
疫情期间关在家里曾经是为人母的典型经历。有人认为疫苗实际上使女性得以工作。希拉里是一名电台DJ，疫情期间她和丈夫分工配合。
My husband would wake up and go to work at 6:00 AM, and just see all his customers early. He would try and be home by noon. And we would literally high five. I would hand him Finlee. And I would take off running, be live 1:00 to 3:00, pre-tape the following morning, and on and on. It was crazy.
我丈夫早上6点醒来去工作，尽早见完客户。他会尽量在中午回家。我们真的会击掌。我会把芬莉交给他，然后我飞奔出门，在下午1点到3点直播，为第二天早上预录节目，如此往复。这简直疯了。
So when you're pre-recording the following morning, you're saying, it's Tuesday morning, it's sunny and 80 degrees outside in San Diego today.
所以当你预录第二天早上的节目时，你会说：“今天是周二早上，圣迭戈天气晴朗，气温80度。”
Yeah, and this song is for so and so who just called from Rancho Bernardo. I mean you have to make it sound like it's real.
是的，还有这首歌送给刚从兰乔贝尔纳多打进电话的某某。我的意思是，你必须让它听起来很真实。
There's The Cardigans on San Diego Star 94.1. It's Hilary. I've been getting so many calls about Jeff and Jared's thank you party. If you need the info, it's on--
这里是圣迭戈之星94.1电台的卡迪根合唱团，我是希拉里。我接到了很多关于杰夫和贾里德答谢派对的电话。如果你需要信息，请在——
Even though Hilary was planning on getting Finlee vaccinated for measles, she was hesitant about it. Vaccine anxiety is pretty standard for a certain kind of over-protective mother-- and I count myself among them-- one who shops at Whole Foods and worries about chemicals in plastic and toys made in China. The shots are scary, because first of all, they're not all natural. There's no organic version of the diphtheria shot. And second of all, you have no control over them, unlike you do over the rest of what goes into your child's body.
尽管希拉里计划给芬莉接种麻疹疫苗，但她还是有些犹豫。对于某些过度保护的母亲来说，疫苗焦虑是非常普遍的——我自己也算其中之一——比如那些在全食超市购物，担心塑料中的化学物质以及中国制造玩具的母亲。疫苗接种很可怕，首先，它们不是纯天然的。白喉疫苗没有有机版本。其次，你对疫苗没有控制权，不像你对自己孩子摄入的其他东西有控制权。
Free range, non-hormone meat, organic milk and yogurt, I mean we're pretty careful. Organic fruits and vegetables, the lotion that I put on her, the toys, all of that. And I can regulate that. And I have control over that. But a vaccine, it's like you're handing your child over to the doctor and saying, OK, now inject her with something that I have no idea what it is. And it's supposed to be good for them eventually and protect them. And I hope it does. But--
散养、无激素的肉类，有机牛奶和酸奶，我们真的很小心。有机水果和蔬菜，我给孩子用的乳液、玩具，所有这些。我可以调节，我有控制权。但疫苗就像你把孩子交给医生说：“好了，现在给她注射我根本不知道是什么的东西。”它最终应该对孩子有好处并保护他们，我希望如此，但是……
So is there a way in which you feel like you understand the Switzerland family? You understand their mindset about the vaccines?
那么你觉得你能理解那个瑞士家庭吗？你理解他们对疫苗的心态吗？
No.
不。
Well, I'm sorry. I take that back. I do. As far as choosing not to vaccinate, yes. I definitely get that. I definitely understand that it's scary. And getting vaccinated, I feel like, is a leap of faith. I think the battle starts when one person's choices affect other people. So one person's-- how their child exposed all these other kids, I mean that's a really big deal. And that's just really not being a responsible member of this community, I feel like.
好吧，抱歉。我收回刚才的话。我理解。就选择不接种疫苗而言，是的。我绝对明白，我肯定理解那很可怕。而且我觉得接种疫苗是一种信念的飞跃。我认为当一个人的选择影响到其他人时，矛盾就产生了。所以一个人的行为——那个家庭的孩子如何传染了其他所有孩子，这确实是一件大事。我觉得这真的不是社区负责任成员的表现。
If you've heard anything about vaccines at all, it's probably this. That there's a controversy about whether the shots lead to autism. This idea goes back about 10 years to a paper about the MMR vaccine-- that's measles, mumps and rubella-- that was published in the British medical journal, The Lancet .
如果你听说过任何关于疫苗的消息，大概就是这个：关于疫苗是否会导致自闭症的争议。这个观点可以追溯到大约10年前关于MMR疫苗（麻疹、腮腺炎和风疹）的一篇论文，发表在英国医学期刊《柳叶刀》上。
That paper has since been discredited. The journal actually retracted it. Study after study confirms that the shot does not cause autism. But it's hard to shake the fear that it might be true, partly because every mom has heard stories of kids who became autistic after getting the MMR shot. There are YouTube videos.
那篇论文后来已被推翻，期刊也撤回了它。一项又一项的研究证实，该疫苗不会导致自闭症。但那种恐惧很难消除，部分原因是每位母亲都听过孩子在接种MMR后患上自闭症的故事。YouTube上到处都是这类视频。
Hi Eric. [BABY LAUGHING]
嗨，埃里克。[婴儿笑声]
The stories usually go like this. A mom takes her totally normal baby to the doctor. That baby gets the MMR shot. In the days that follow, he stops babbling, stops making eye contact, just slips inside himself and is never the same again.
故事通常是这样的：一位母亲带一个完全正常的婴儿去医生那里，孩子接种了MMR疫苗。在随后的日子里，他停止了咿呀学语，停止了眼神交流，陷入了自己的世界，再也没有恢复正常。
Eric, hey.
埃里克，嘿。
But saying it plainly-- there is no causal relationship between the vaccine and autism-- is asking for a fight. One of the autism researchers I interviewed was reluctant to speak on the radio. He sent me an email about a colleague who has received death threats for saying there's no connection between autism and the MMR. Real death threats, as in when the guy goes to lunch at the CDC in Atlanta he has bodyguards. All the articles I looked at online for this story are the kind that have 1,000 vitriolic comments underneath. And it's not just anti-vaccinators who are saying crazy, mean stuff. There are haters on both sides.
但是明确地说——疫苗和自闭症之间没有因果关系——是在自找麻烦。我采访的一位自闭症研究员不愿在广播中发表意见。他给我发了一封电子邮件，提到一位同事因为声称自闭症和MMR之间没有联系而收到死亡威胁。真正的死亡威胁，当那个人在亚特兰大的CDC吃午饭时，他有保镖陪同。我在网上为这篇报道查阅的所有文章，下面都有上千条尖刻的评论。而且不仅仅是反疫苗者在说些疯狂、刻薄的话，双方都有仇恨者。
I've been called a murderer, potential murder, more than once.
我曾不止一次被称为凶手，潜在的凶手。
This is Sybil Carlson. During the outbreak, she talked to a lot of reporters about how she doesn't vaccinate her children.
这是西比尔·卡尔森。在疫情爆发期间，她接受了很多记者的采访，谈论她为什么不给孩子接种疫苗。
Ugh, it's just over and over. I don't know how many blogs I was on where, don't I care about anybody else's children? And don't I know that the FDA and the CDC say this is all perfectly safe? And I shouldn't question them. And what am I talking about? I'm just a mom, I don't have any medical degrees.
唉，真是没完没了。我都不知道上了多少博客，人们问：我不关心别人的孩子吗？难道我不知道FDA和CDC说这些完全安全吗？我不应该质疑他们。我在说什么？我只是个妈妈，我没有医学学位。
Sybil is friends with the mom who went to Switzerland. When the outbreak happened, the Switzerland mom didn't want to talk to the media. In fact, almost none of the non-vaccinators would except Sybil, who became the Switzerland mom's de facto stand in. She and her friends all got together one day. The kids played on the back deck while the mothers hammered out Sybil's talking points. And then Sybil went home and started taking calls from reporters.
西比尔是那个去过瑞士的妈妈的朋友。疫情爆发时，瑞士妈妈不想和媒体说话。事实上，几乎没有反疫苗者愿意说话，除了西比尔，她成了瑞士妈妈事实上的发言人。有一天，她和朋友们聚在一起。孩子们在后甲板上玩，妈妈们商定西比尔的谈话要点。然后西比尔回家，开始接听记者的电话。
Our phone was just ringing off the hook. And my husband would be like, it's Time Magazine, it's The Today Show, it's Nightline. I mean, it was just every single day. He started laughing because these people were just calling from left and right, because, OK, she'll talk. And in the beginning, I would. I'm like, yeah yeah, I'm going to get this information out there. And I'm going to really tell them about this. And I'm just going to change people's thinking.
我们的电话被打爆了。我丈夫会说：“又是《时代》周刊，又是《今日秀》，又是《夜线》。”我的意思是，每天都是这样。他开始笑，因为这些人从四面八方打来，因为“好吧，她会说话”。起初我会接，我想，太好了，我要把这些信息传出去，我要真正告诉他们这些情况，我要改变人们的想法。
No. The media has an agenda. And the agenda is to take someone like me, and nitpick apart, and edit to the point where basically, you were scared. You read some bad things. So you didn't vaccinate because you didn't want your children to be autistic. But it's so much more than that.
不。媒体是有议程的，这个议程就是找像我这样的人，挑刺、剪辑，直到让你害怕。你读到了一些糟糕的事情，所以你没给孩子接种疫苗，因为你不想让孩子患上自闭症。但这远不止于此。
For parents like Sybil who don't vaccinate, autism is just one concern. They're also worried about autoimmune diseases and unknown long term health effects that they believe are caused by lots of different vaccines. They cite medical studies and data they suspect aren't telling us the whole truth about vaccine safety.
对于像西比尔这样不接种疫苗的家长来说，自闭症只是一个担忧。他们还担心自身免疫性疾病和未知的长期健康影响，他们认为这些是由许多不同的疫苗引起的。他们引用他们怀疑没有告诉我们疫苗安全性全部真相的医学研究和数据。
I'm pretty sympathetic to this stuff. When Sybil says that aluminum, a vaccine additive, is a known neurotoxin, I'm right there with her. But other things sound shakier. Still, what anyone can understand is the essence of Sybil's position, which is this. She doesn't trust the system. And you're not going to vaccinate if you don't have that faith.
我对这些东西相当同情。当西比尔说疫苗添加剂铝是一种已知的神经毒素时，我完全站在她这边。但其他东西听起来就比较动摇了。不过，任何人都能理解西比尔立场的核心，那就是：她不信任这个系统。如果你没有那种信心，你就不可能去接种疫苗。
That's the difference between Sybil and parents who do vaccinate. It's not that they're more altruistic. It's just that they trust the system and she doesn't. Sybil deeply believes that getting a shot could permanently harm her child. And that's scary, especially when a doctor is trying to bully you into vaccinating. She tells the story of a time she took her son to the emergency room for a dog bite, and she got into an argument with the doctor about whether her son needed a tetanus shot.
这就是西比尔和接种疫苗的家长之间的区别。并不是后者更无私，只是他们信任这个系统，而她不信。西比尔深信接种疫苗可能会永久损害她的孩子。这很可怕，特别是当医生试图恐吓你接种疫苗时。她讲述了有一次带儿子去急诊室处理狗咬伤的事情，她和医生就儿子是否需要接种破伤风疫苗发生了争执。
We went back and forth. And he became very angry at me, and started chastising me for not giving my children-- "I can't believe he didn't have a pertussis vaccination. Why wouldn't you give him the whole DTaP series?" And he said, "What's your problem with the vaccinations?" I think it's probably 1 o'clock in the morning at this point. I've been up half the night. My child has been fussy and crying. And I'm sort of at this point really having a hard time defending myself.
我们争执不下。他对我非常生气，开始责备我不给孩子接种疫苗。“我简直不敢相信他没有接种百日咳疫苗。你为什么不让他接种全套DTaP？”他说：“你对疫苗有什么意见？”我想当时大约是凌晨1点。我已经熬了大半夜。孩子一直烦躁不安、哭闹。在那种情况下，我真的很难为自己辩护。
And he really, really pushed and harped on me. And he scared me. He started using scare tactics. He's going to get sepsis. He's going to die. And they're not related to tetanus. And his agenda-- really, I could tell that point-- was he was going to get a DTaP tap into my child, because he felt like he could force me to. I did give in, which during further research I realized later even talking to my doctor, was just completely unnecessary. So that just ruined my faith even more. It sort of hit me. Wow, is it really this bad? So that was a big moment for me.
他真的、真的逼得很紧。他吓唬我，开始使用恐吓战术：他会得败血症，他会死，等等。这些和破伤风都没关系。他的议程——我当时确实看出来了——是他打算把DTaP强加给我孩子，因为他觉得他可以强迫我。我最终屈服了，后来进一步研究甚至与我的医生交流后，我意识到那是完全没必要的。这让我的信心更彻底地破灭了。它触动了我：哇，情况真的有这么糟糕吗？那对我来说是个重大的时刻。
Sybil gets that by not vaccinating her children, she's putting other children at risk. She doesn't dispute that. But she thinks it's unacceptable that her kids, or anyone's kids, should have to risk serious side effects from a vaccine. So until she's satisfied that the vaccine system is safer, she's willing to risk her kids getting the measles. But I spoke to another mother in San Diego who thought that choice seemed absurd.
西比尔明白，不给孩子接种疫苗，她就是让其他孩子面临风险。她并不否认这一点。但她认为，让她的孩子，或者任何人的孩子，必须冒着接种疫苗产生严重副作用的风险是不可接受的。所以，直到她确信疫苗系统更安全之前，她愿意冒着孩子患上麻疹的风险。但我采访了圣迭戈的另一位母亲，她认为这种选择显得极其荒谬。
And then the rash started getting worse. It just started spreading further down into his body.
然后皮疹开始恶化，开始进一步蔓延到他全身。
This is Megan Campbell. Her son was 10 months old when he was exposed to measles in the pediatrician's office, which he visited on the same day as the Switzerland family. Megan's baby was one of the first kids affected in the outbreak, before everyone put together what was going on. The doctor kept telling her it was just a run of the mill virus. But as the days went by, Megan's son kept getting sicker.
这是梅根·坎贝尔。她儿子10个月大时，在儿科医生的诊室里接触到了麻疹，那是她和那个瑞士家庭同一天去的地方。梅根的宝宝是疫情中首批受影响的孩子之一，当时还没人搞清楚发生了什么。医生一直告诉她这只是普通的病毒感染。但随着日子一天天过去，梅根儿子的病情越来越重。
Come Saturday, my parents came down from Los Angeles, and took one look at him and said, your kid has the measles. Because they come from a generation that knows what it looks like. Well at that point, my son had the full rash all the way to his toes. And we would never put him down even for a nap. So like I said, my parents were down to help so that someone was always holding him, because I was honestly very afraid to put him down and lose him. I thought as long as we were holding him, then we knew his heart was beating.
到了周六，我父母从洛杉矶下来，看了一眼就说：“你孩子得了麻疹。”因为他们那一代人知道麻疹是什么样。那时，我儿子全身都长满了皮疹，直到脚趾。我们甚至连小睡时都不敢放下他。正如我所说的，我父母下来帮忙，这样总有人抱着他，因为我真的很怕放下他，怕失去他。我想只要我们抱着他，就知道他的心还在跳。
Megan took her son to the emergency room. When she told them he might have measles, it took two hours for them to figure out how to get him inside the hospital without exposing everyone else. Finally, they came out with a blanket, wrapped him up, and rushed him into a secure room. He dropped from 18 pounds to 12 pounds in five days.
梅根带儿子去了急诊室。当她告诉他们孩子可能得了麻疹时，他们花了两个小时才想出如何让孩子进入医院而不传染给其他人。最后，他们拿来一条毯子把他包起来，冲进一个隔离室。他在五天内体重从18磅掉到了12磅。
The first thing they had to do was put in an IV. He was so dehydrated that his veins had collapsed. It took an hour and four nurses to get a needle into his wrist. Her son was screaming. Megan couldn't take it. She had to leave the room.
他们首先必须做的是注射静脉输液。他脱水太严重，静脉已经塌陷了。四名护士花了一个小时才把针扎进他的手腕。她儿子一直在尖叫。梅根受不了，不得不离开房间。
There were moments when I was worried that he wouldn't make it because this fever just wasn't letting up. This 106 fever and this rash that made my son look like an alien almost. And I almost wondered if he was going to look-- if he was going to be the same boy that he was a week before.
有那么一刻，我担心他挺不过去了，因为那高烧一直不退。那是106度的高烧，皮疹让我儿子看起来简直像个外星人。我甚至怀疑——他会不会像一周前那样还是同一个男孩。
And I was a mom who has taken probably 50 pictures of my son every day since he was born. And there are no pictures of him from the moment that he got this until he was finally better, because it wasn't my son. And I never want to remember him looking that way.
我是个自他出生起每天可能给他拍50张照片的妈妈。但从他患病到最终好转，没有任何照片，因为那不是我的儿子，我永远不想记住他那副样子。
While Megan's son was in the hospital, news of the outbreak hit.
当梅根的儿子在医院时，疫情的新闻爆发了。
And I just wondered how this family who had brought this into San Diego, were they watching this television and what were they thinking? Were they thinking that they were part of something that put that child there? Or did they feel for us at all? Did they feel bad about it?
我只是想，把这带到圣迭戈的那个家庭，他们在看电视吗？他们在想什么？他们认为自己是导致那个孩子变成那样的原因之一吗？他们会为我们感到难过吗？他们感到内疚吗？
Megan's son was sick for weeks. Megan and her husband both had to take a month off work. They were dumping him into ice baths when his fever spiked, constantly watching for side effects of the measles, blindness, brain swelling. When it was all over, Megan and her husband found they couldn't engage in the vaccine debate.
梅根的儿子病了几个星期。梅根和丈夫都不得不请了一个月的假。当孩子发高烧时，他们把他泡进冰浴里，时刻警惕着麻疹的副作用：失明、脑肿胀。一切结束后，梅根和丈夫发现他们无法参与疫苗辩论。
And I have very close friends who don't vaccinate their children. And it's just something that we can't talk about. We get too angry. We can barely speak. I feel like if I were to engage in the conversation, we might not be friends anymore.
我有一些非常亲密的朋友也不给孩子接种疫苗。这成了我们无法谈论的话题。我们太生气了，几乎说不出话来。我觉得如果我参与这种谈话，我们可能就做不成朋友了。
Do you think it should be a choice? Do you think people should be able to opt out of the measles vaccine?
你认为这应该是一个选择吗？你认为人们应该可以选择不接种麻疹疫苗吗？
Yes, but they have to live on an island. Their own little, infectious disease island. Don't go to the same doctors as the rest of us. Don't go to the same schools. Don't go to the same stores. Live on an island somewhere if that's the choice you want to make.
可以，但他们必须住在岛上。他们自己的那种感染疾病的岛上。别去和我们剩下的人看同一个医生。别去同一所学校，别去同一家商店。如果那是你想做的选择，就去岛上住吧。
But families that opt out of vaccines don't live on an island. They live all over the country, and there are more of them all the time, which is why they are of such concern to the CDC. They threaten the herd. There's this vaccine concept called herd immunity, which means that if a certain percentage of the population is immunized, it's really hard for diseases to spread. And so the most vulnerable people-- babies, people with weak immune systems, old people-- are protected. But when you fall below that percentage, suddenly infections jump exponentially.
但选择不接种疫苗的家庭不住在岛上。他们住在这个国家的各个地方，而且数量越来越多，这就是为什么他们让CDC如此担忧。他们威胁到了群体免疫。有个疫苗概念叫“群体免疫”，意味着如果一定比例的人群接种了疫苗，疾病就很难传播。因此，最脆弱的人群——婴儿、免疫系统较弱的人、老年人——都能得到保护。但一旦低于这个比例，感染就会呈指数级跳升。
And that's what happened here during the last measles epidemic almost 20 years ago, when 123 people died. Back then it was poor kids who weren't getting immunized, kids who didn't have access to the shots. Now it's the well-off kids of highly educated parents. So the CDC is spending a lot of time right now trying to figure out why these parents aren't vaccinating, just trying to understand their concerns. And they're working on a booklet to help doctors deliver the message better, how to reassure nervous parents. And parents nervous about vaccines are legion. A lot of them go to this guy.
这就是近20年前最后一次麻疹流行时发生的情况，当时有123人死亡。那时是穷人家的孩子没能免疫，那些没机会接种疫苗的孩子。现在则是受过良好教育、家境殷实的家庭的孩子。所以CDC目前投入了大量时间试图弄清楚为什么这些家长不给孩子接种疫苗，只是想理解他们的担忧。他们正在编写一本手册，帮助医生更好地传达信息，如何安抚紧张的家长。而对疫苗感到紧张的家长数不胜数，很多人都去找这个人。
My experience, though, with parents, when they're making vaccine decisions, they're not thinking public health policy or public health safety. They're thinking about just their own child's health. But what can I say? I say, I understand. You have the right to make that choice.
不过，我与家长的经验是，当他们做疫苗决定时，他们考虑的不是公共卫生政策或公共卫生安全，他们只关心自己孩子的健康。但我能说什么？我会说，我理解。你有权做出那个选择。
That's Dr. Bob Sears. He's one of the sons of the famous Dr. Sears, William Sears, and author of a big parenting manual, kind of a bible for crunchy moms. Dr. Bob, as people call him, is also the doctor for the non-vaccinating family that went to Switzerland. He's had thousands of conversations with parents about whether they should vaccinate. He's written a book on the subject.
那是鲍勃·西尔斯医生。他是著名的威廉·西尔斯医生之子，也是一本大型育儿手册的作者，某种程度上是那些崇尚自然家长的“圣经”。人们称他为“鲍勃医生”，他也是那个去过瑞士的未接种疫苗家庭的医生。他与家长进行过数千次关于是否应该接种疫苗的对话。他写了一本关于这个主题的书。
In my book, I actually speak to this issue using an analogy from one of the all time greatest TV shows ever, Star Trek. There's a great quote in Star Trek where Spock says, "The needs of the many outweigh the needs of the few or the one." And there is no better way you can look at that than with vaccines. And Spock was saying this in the movie while he was dying to save the Starship Enterprise. And would Spock's mom have said her son made a good decision, because she had to lose her son over it? It's a big dilemma. And I honestly must say I think parents ultimately are going to choose what they view is best for the one instead of looking at what's best for the many.
在我的书中，我实际上使用了一部史上最伟大电视节目之一的类比来探讨这个问题：《星际迷航》。《星际迷航》中有一句名言，史波克说：“多数人的需求重于少数人或个人的需求。”用疫苗来看待这个问题再合适不过了。史波克在电影中牺牲自己以拯救联邦星舰企业号时说了这句话。史波克的母亲会说她的儿子做出了正确的决定吗？因为她必须因此失去儿子。这是一个巨大的困境。我诚实地说，我认为家长最终会选择他们认为对个人最有利的方式，而不是考虑对多数人最有利的方式。
Have you ever used that Star Trek line in your office with a sci-fi type dad who was won over?
在你的诊所里，你有没有和科幻迷爸爸用过那句《星际迷航》的台词，并成功说服他们？
Yeah, if there is a geeky dad. Oh yeah, of course, I like to pull that out.
是的，如果有那种极客爸爸。哦是的，当然，我喜欢用这招。
And does that convert a hesitant vaccinator?
那能转化一个犹豫不决的疫苗接种者吗？
No. No, of course not. No. The CDC has found the same thing as Dr. Bob, that this argument just doesn't work. After the outbreak in San Diego, the CDC conducted focus groups with some of the parents involved. And one of the things they discovered was that the outbreak didn't change anybody's mind. The intentionally unvaccinated kids who got the measles came through it just fine, which proved to their parents that measles is kind of like chicken pox, not that big a deal.
不，当然不行。CDC发现了和鲍勃医生同样的结果，即这个论点根本行不通。圣迭戈疫情爆发后，CDC对一些相关家长进行了焦点小组讨论。他们发现的一件事是，疫情并没有改变任何人的想法。那些故意未接种疫苗而患上麻疹的孩子康复得很好，这向他们的父母证明了：麻疹就像水痘一样，没什么大不了的。
On the other side, the pro-vaccinators felt ratified, like, see, it's good to get the shot because these diseases do come around. Because even though the measles connected everyone in San Diego, everybody experienced the outbreak in their own little quarantine.
另一方面，疫苗支持者感到得到了证实，认为：“看，接种疫苗是好事，因为这些疾病确实会卷土重来。”因为尽管麻疹将圣迭戈的每个人联系在一起，但每个人都以自己小小的隔离方式经历了这次疫情。
Susan Burton in New York.
纽约的苏珊·伯顿。
[MUSIC - "GIRL, YOU HAVE NO FAITH IN MEDICINE" BY THE WHITE STRIPES]
[音乐 - 白条纹乐队的《女孩，你不相信医学》]
Coming up, what it's like to be invited to a big charity event that you then ruin. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
稍后，被邀请参加大型慈善活动却搞砸了是什么体验。更多精彩内容，一分钟后回到芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Ruining It for the Rest of Us, stories of people who are accused of ruining everything for everybody else or who simply know that they are doing that. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Tragedy Minus Comedy Equals Time, specifically a long, long time between laughs.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种相关故事。今天的节目主题是“为了我们其他人搞砸了”，讲述的是那些被指控搞砸了所有人的事，或者仅仅是知道自己正在这样做的人的故事。现在到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，喜剧减去悲剧等于时间，具体来说是在欢笑之间等待了漫长的、漫长的时间。
Mike Birbiglia is the kind of working comedian who tours, and he does specials on Comedy Central , but he is not exactly a household name. Recently, he told an audience about a bad experience he had as a performer, one where he personally did not rise to the occasion. In fact, he says it was the worst show he's ever done in his life.
麦克·伯比利亚是一位到处巡演的职业喜剧演员，他在喜剧中心频道有个人特辑，但他还算不上家喻户晓。最近，他告诉观众他作为表演者的一次糟糕经历，在那次活动中他个人表现得很差劲。事实上，他说这是他一生中最糟糕的一次演出。
It happened this year. I was asked to perform at a charity golf tournament in New Jersey. So I woke up for this charity golf event, and I have a-- I realized recently that I'm not a good adult yet. Like I think if you're if a good adult, you plan your outfit according to what will occur when you leave the house. But I don't have that part of my brain. I'm just like, one outfit forever.
这发生在今年。我被邀请在新泽西州的一场慈善高尔夫球赛上表演。所以那天我醒来去参加这个活动，我最近意识到我还不算一个好的成年人。我觉得如果你是个好的成年人，你会根据出门后要做什么来计划你的穿着。但我脑子里没有那部分。我只是想，“一套衣服走天下”。
So I went and I played golf. And I brought my brother Joe. And Joe is kind of like a bad entourage member. He's never like, you the man, Mike. He 's always like, I don't know what dad would think about this. And, do you think they have any more shrimp? That kind of thing.
所以我去打高尔夫球了，带上了我弟弟乔。乔有点像个糟糕的随从。他从来不会说“麦克，你是最棒的”，他总是说“我不确定老爸会怎么想这个”，或者“你觉得还有虾吗？”之类的。
But we showed up to play golf and they paired us up with these two other people. It was a celebrity tournament. And the people were like, who do you think our celebrity is going to be? [LAUGHTER]
但我们到了那里去打高尔夫，他们把我们和另外两个人分在一组。那是一场明星锦标赛。人们当时就在想：“你觉得我们的明星会是谁？” [笑声]
And Joe and I were like, yeah, who do you think our celebrity is going to be? And then I'm like, oh no, I think it might be me. And then I'm apologizing to these people. I'm like I'm really sorry I'm your celebrity. If you think this is disappointing for you, you can't imagine how I feel.
我和乔当时就在想：“是啊，你觉得我们的明星会是谁？”然后我想：“哦不，我觉得可能就是我。”然后我开始向那些人道歉，我说：“真的很抱歉我是你们的明星。如果你觉得这让你失望，你无法想象我的感受。”
So I'm apologizing the whole day. And then at the end of the day, sure enough my pants are all wrinkled. And I have to be at this performance, this semi-formal banquet. And I'm like, what about one outfit forever? I thought that was a good plan. And so here's what I do. As damage control, I go to the locker room to iron my own pants. And yeah, it's a pretty good plan. And I find an iron, but I couldn't find a board. So I take off my pants. I'm just ironing them on a bench in the locker room in my underwear, which is a dead giveaway that these are my only pants.
所以我整天都在道歉。到了最后，不出所料，我的裤子全皱了。我必须参加那场半正式的宴会表演，我心想：“说好的‘一套衣服走天下’呢？我还以为那是个好计划。”于是我做了什么？作为补救措施，我去了更衣室熨裤子。是的，这计划听起来不错。我找到了熨斗，但找不到熨衣板。所以我脱掉裤子，只穿着内衣在更衣室的长凳上熨裤子。这绝对暴露了我只有这一条裤子的事实。
So I'm ironing my pants. And I put them on, and I go up to the event. And this is where the trouble really begins. It's important for me, before I tell you this part of the story, to remind you that you're on my side. [LAUGHTER]
所以我熨好了裤子穿上，走到了活动现场。Trouble真正开始的地方就在这里。在讲这部分故事前，提醒你们站在这边很重要。[笑声]
I say to the woman in charge, I go what's the format of the show? And she goes, well there are two speakers, and then you, and then a raffle. And I was like, well that's exciting, because I've never opened for a raffle. And I'm trying to stay optimistic.
我问负责人：“表演形式是什么？”她说：“有两位演讲者，然后是你，最后是抽奖。”我说：“那太令人兴奋了，因为我从未为抽奖做过开场嘉宾。”我试图保持乐观。
And I'm sitting in the back of the room with my brother Joe, and the first speaker comes on the stage. And he's an 11 year old boy who survived leukemia. I know. He's not funny at all. [LAUGHTER] He focuses primarily on the leukemia, and everyone is crying, literally everyone is crying. I'm even crying in the back of the room for two reasons. One, the kid, and two, for me, because I have to perform comedy.
我和弟弟乔坐在房间后面，第一位演讲者登台了。他是一个11岁的白血病幸存者。我知道，他一点也不好笑。[笑声] 他主要集中在白血病上，每个人都在哭，真的是每个人都在哭。我也在房间后面哭，有两个原因：第一，为了那个孩子；第二，为了我自己，因为我必须表演喜剧。
And it gets worse, because Joe leans over and he goes, this ain't looking so good Mike. [LAUGHTER] I said, I concur.
情况变得更糟，因为乔靠过来对我说：“麦克，看起来不太好啊。” [笑声] 我说：“我同意。”
The second speaker was Hall of Fame quarterback Phil Simms. And yeah, he's got one fan here. But he's a broadcaster. And he gives an amazing, inspiring speech. And he even sprinkles in a few jokes about golf that were similar to jokes I had thought of about golf that day. It was like watching the last drops of my joke canteen drip out onto a desert of cancer. [LAUGHTER]
第二位演讲者是名人堂四分卫菲尔·西姆斯。好吧，他这里有一个粉丝。但他是一位广播员。他发表了一场精彩且鼓舞人心的演讲，甚至还穿插了几个关于高尔夫的笑话，和我那天想到的差不多。看着我仅存的笑话 canteen 滴在癌症的沙漠里，那种感觉……[笑声]
He gets a standing ovation, which he should have. Clearly the show is over. Surely there can't be anyone more famous than Hall of Fame quarterback Phil Simms. But wait, there was. It was Mike Birbiglia, who had no business being at this event. I know there are some entertainers who might have risen to the challenge. And I would love to be one of those entertainers, but I am not.
他获得了全场起立鼓掌，这是他应得的。很明显，演出已经结束了。肯定不可能有比名人堂四分卫菲尔·西姆斯更出名的人了。但等等，还真有，那就是麦克·伯比利亚，他根本没理由出现在这个活动上。我知道有些艺人可能会迎接挑战，我很希望能成为那样的艺人，但我不是。
As a matter of fact, I have a habit in my life of making awkward situations even more awkward. I've said this before, but a few years ago I was moving a new bed into my apartment. And this woman who lived in the building opened the front door for me with her key. And she goes, "I'm not worried, because a rapist wouldn't have a bed like that." That's how she started the conversation. Now what I should have said was nothing. What I did say was, "You'd be surprised." [LAUGHTER] And there's nothing you can say after that. You're just like, see you around the building, that kind of thing.
事实上，我的人生中有一种习惯，就是让尴尬的情况变得更加尴尬。我以前说过，但几年前我在搬一张新床到公寓时，住在那栋楼里的一个女人用钥匙帮我开了前门，她说：“我不担心，因为强奸犯不会有那样的床。”这就是她开始对话的方式。我当时应该什么都不说，但我说的是：“你可能会感到惊讶。” [笑声] 那之后你就什么也接不上了。你只能说：“楼里再见”之类的话。
I've thought about this a lot. And I think there's something wrong with my brain where I don't have an on deck circle for ideas. It's just, batter up. And a lot of the ideas are bad. And they're at the plate going, I don't know about this one Mike. And I just turn into this drunk little league dad. I'm like, you gonna take some cuts, son. [LAUGHTER]
我思考过很多，我觉得我的大脑出了问题，我没有想法的预备区。直接就是：“击球手准备”。很多想法都很糟糕。它们在击球区时心里在说：“我不确定这个行不行，麦克。”我直接变成了一个喝醉的少年棒球联盟父亲，我说：“你得挥几下，孩子。” [笑声]
As a comedian, when people laugh it's very exciting. It's a very neat thing. And when they don't, it feels like you're performing jazz. Because they're kind of bobbing their head and looking to the side. And sometimes that's OK. I'm like, I like jazz. But then I get worried, because I'm like sometimes jazz sucks. What if I'm the Kenny G of comedy? What if I think I sound like this, [MIMICS JAZZ] and in fact I sound like this, [MIMICS SMOOTH JAZZ].
作为一名喜剧演员，人们大笑时非常令人兴奋。这是一件非常美妙的事。但当他们不笑时，感觉就像在表演爵士乐。因为他们会点头，然后看向旁边。有时没关系，我会想：“我喜欢爵士乐。”但接着我会担心，因为我觉得有时爵士乐很烂。如果我是喜剧界的肯尼·基（Kenny G）怎么办？如果我觉得我听起来像这样 [模仿爵士乐]，但事实上我听起来像这样 [模仿平淡的爵士乐]？
So I'm on stage at the charity golf tournament. And I'm just Kenny G'ing it up. I'm just-- for 10 minutes-- [MIMICS JAZZ] just blowing that horn. And I don't want to fail. I mean that's a really important point in this story. These are good people. And I want to succeed for them, but I just can't.
所以我在慈善高尔夫球赛的舞台上，我只是在吹奏那该死的肯尼·基风格的音乐。我只是——整整10分钟—— [模仿爵士乐] 一直在那吹。我不想失败，这是这个故事中非常重要的一点。这些是好人，我想为他们成功，但我就是做不到。
And so I think to myself, why don't I cater my material to this specific event? And everyone has been talking about cancer. [LAUGHTER] I know. I'm in the future also. [LAUGHTER] [APPLAUSE] I had that thought on stage for about one second, and then batter up.
于是我想：“为什么不针对这个特定活动调整我的素材呢？”每个人都在谈论癌症。[笑声] 我知道，我也在未来。[笑声] [掌声] 我在舞台上有那么一秒钟闪过这个念头，然后——击球手准备。
I said to the audience-- a true story-- I said I went to the doctor and they told me there was something in my bladder. And whenever they tell you that, it's never anything good, like we found something in your bladder and it's season tickets to the Yankees. [LAUGHTER] That was the response I was hoping for.
我对观众说——这是真事——我说：“我去看医生，他们告诉我我的膀胱里长了东西。”每当他们告诉你那个，从来没什么好事。比如：“我们在你的膀胱里发现了东西，这是洋基队的赛季套票。” [笑声] 那是我期待的回应。
At that point, I just threw in the towel. I mean I was just devastated. I thanked the audience and apologized simultaneously, which I've never done. I was like, thank you, sorry for ruining your event. And I just walked off.
在那一刻，我直接认输了。我被彻底打击了。我同时感谢了观众并道歉，这是我从未做过的。我说：“谢谢，对不起把你们的活动搞砸了。”然后我直接走下了台。
And I was so upset. And I walked over to Joe. And I go, Joe, we are leaving now. And that's when Joe said, and I quote, "Mike, I can't. They're just about to start the raffle." [LAUGHTER] "And because everybody left, my odds are amazing." And that is the worst show I have ever done in my entire life.
我当时非常难过。我走到乔那里说：“乔，我们现在就走。”这时候乔说，我引用一下：“麦克，我不能走。他们马上就要开始抽奖了。” [笑声] “而且因为大家都走了，我的胜算太大了。”这是我一生中做过的最糟糕的演出。
Mike Birbiglia. That story's been recorded on one of his CDs, My Secret Public Journal , which was put out by Comedy Central and can be downloaded online at the iTunes store.
麦克·伯比利亚。那个故事被收录在他的一张CD《我的秘密公共日记》中，由喜剧中心频道发行，可以在iTunes商店在线下载。
[MUSIC - "I STARTED A JOKE," THE BEE GEES]
[音乐 - 比吉斯合唱团的《我开始了一个笑话》]
Act Three, Disturbing the Peace Train. Nothing is too big to be ruined. Entire civilizations have been ruined. Species have vanished from the earth. And yet, something as small, as mundane, as one person's day can also be ruined. Nancy Updike has the story about the lessons to be learned from small scale ruin, and how, by trying to eradicate a problem, one can become the problem.
第三幕：扰乱和平的列车。没有什么太大而不能被搞砸。整个文明都曾被搞砸。物种从地球上消失。然而，像一个人的一天那样微小、平凡的东西也能被搞砸。南希·厄普代克讲述了一个关于从小规模搞砸中汲取教训的故事，以及通过试图根除问题，一个人如何最终成为了问题本身。
This story is going to end up exactly where you'd expect it to, at the entrance to a giant, inflatable large intestine. But first, a few words about bad behavior. [SOUND OF CLIPPING NAILS] This is the sound of a person clipping their nails. And this sound in public, I find, is so unexpected and distinctive that it cuts through any other sound that might be going on, dinner being served, a person giving a speech, the hum of an airplane's cabin. It's possible you're having trouble following the words I'm saying right now because this sound is so disturbing.
这个故事最终会像你预期的那样，结束在一个巨大的充气大肠入口处。但首先，谈谈不良行为。[指甲剪的声音] 这是剪指甲的声音。而在公共场合，我发现这种声音非常突兀和独特，它能穿透任何其他正在进行的声音：晚餐供应、演讲、飞机机舱的轰鸣。你现在可能很难跟上我说话的内容，因为这个声音太让人烦躁了。
Public nail clipping, of course, is rare. Maybe that's why it's so memorable when it does happen. But it's part of a category of activities that isn't rare at all, that is in fact happening every day, cutting in line, parking in two spaces at once, kicking the back of someone's seat during a movie, driving on the shoulder in a traffic jam. When these things are not happening to you, it's easy to say, this is small potatoes. Who cares? But we do care. These are the stories we tell our spouses and friends when they ask how our day was. And the questions we have about these encounters are always the same, is it me? Am I alone in finding this irritating? This is bad public behavior, right? Or am I just a crank?
当然，公共场合剪指甲很少见，也许这就是它发生时如此令人难忘的原因。但这只是每天都在发生的多种活动中的一种：插队、一个停车位停两辆车、在电影院踢别人的椅背、在堵车时占用路肩开车。当这些事没有发生在自己身上时，很容易说：“这都是小事，谁在乎呢？”但我们在乎。这些是我们告诉配偶和朋友关于一天经历的故事。而关于这些遭遇，我们的问题总是相同的：是我的问题吗？只有我觉得这很烦人吗？这是公共场合的不当行为，对吧？还是说我只是个怪人？
The only way to know for sure is to find other people who feel the same way, which brings us to Amtrak.
确定这一点唯一的方法就是找到其他有同样感受的人，这就把我们带到了美国铁路公司（Amtrak）。
Good evening ladies and gentlemen. As a reminder, if you hear this announcement, you are in the Quiet Car. There are no cell phones permitted to use. Your conversations must be maintained at a whisper level. And no electronic devices that emit noise are permitted while in the Quiet Car. Thank you very much for your cooperation. Have a pleasant trip.
各位女士、各位先生，晚上好。温馨提醒：如果您听到此广播，您就在“安静车厢”。严禁使用手机。谈话必须保持耳语级别。安静车厢内禁止使用任何产生噪音的电子设备。非常感谢您的配合。祝您旅途愉快。
Now some of you may already have heard of the Quiet Car, but briefly what happened is this. Amtrak's East Coast route from Washington to Boston that goes through Philadelphia and New York is Amtrak's most profitable and most heavily traveled route. And about 10 years ago, a bunch of frequent Philly to DC travelers started asking Amtrak if there could please be one car on the train, just one, in which people would shut up. No cell phones, no beeping games, no yammering. Silence.
现在，有些人可能已经听说过“安静车厢”。简单来说发生了什么：美国铁路公司从华盛顿到波士顿，途经费城和纽约的东海岸线路，是美国最赚钱、客流量最大的线路。大约10年前，一群往返费城和华盛顿的常客开始请求美国铁路公司，能否在车上设置一节车厢，哪怕只有一节，让人们安静下来？没有手机，没有鸣叫的游戏，没有聒噪。绝对的宁静。
The Quiet Car was a huge hit. Amtrak added Quiet Cars to more routes and more times of day. Commuter rail lines started calling about setting up their own Quiet Cars. Amtrak trademarked the name Quiet Car.
“安静车厢”大受欢迎。美国铁路公司在更多线路和更多时段增加了安静车厢。通勤铁路线开始询问如何设置自己的安静车厢。美国铁路公司将“安静车厢”注册为商标。
Now if the idea of the Quiet Car doesn't appeal to you, just imagine a place where the thing that annoys you most is forbidden, whatever it is. A friend of mine hates it when people in the grocery store get bagels out of the bin with their hands instead of using the little pieces of wax paper. It would be as though she went to the grocery store and they had a special room set aside where bare hands in the bins was not permitted. Utopia.
如果你对“安静车厢”这个想法不感兴趣，试想一下，如果有一个地方，把你最反感的事情都禁掉，无论那是什么。我的一个朋友讨厌杂货店里有人用手而不是小纸片去取百吉饼。这就好比她去了杂货店，对方设了一个专门禁止裸手接触食物的房间。乌托邦。
I started traveling almost every week between Washington and New York, three and a half hours each way. And here's how it went for me in the Quiet Car. Stage one, glee tinged with self-righteousness. See? I'm not an uptight crank. This is an entire train car full of people who agree with me. I am not alone. Stage two, I am an uptight crank. And here's the kind of uptight crank I am. I started taking notes.
我开始几乎每周都在华盛顿和纽约之间往返，单程三个半小时。我在安静车厢的经历是这样的：第一阶段，自我满足的狂喜。看吧？我不是个紧张的怪人。这一整节车厢的人都同意我的观点。我不是一个人。第二阶段，我成了个紧张的怪人。这就是我这种怪人的样子：我开始做记录。
August 12, when you walk into the Quiet Car, people look up at you to see whether you're a member of the club. Are you someone who knows the rules and is here on purpose, or are you one of the others, some regular traveling schmo who stumbled into the car by accident, has no idea where you are, and is going to whip out your cell  phone and ruin everything?
8月12日，当你走进安静车厢，人们会抬头看你，看你是不是俱乐部的一员。你是知道规则并特意来这里的人，还是属于那类人——某个不小心误入车厢、完全不知道自己在哪里、准备拿出手机搞砸一切的普通旅客？
October 18, a scene in the Quiet Car. A man in a suit starts talking on his cell phone. The man sitting behind him asks him not to use his cell phone. Man in suit, "Relax buddy." Man behind him, "You relax and follow the rules." Suddenly it's mayhem. An old man stands up and says, "Yes, follow the rules. I hope you respect the rules." The man behind the cell phone talker piles on, "Respect the rules. Ignorant people don't respect rules." For a moment it seems like it could actually get violent. But it doesn't. The man on the cell phone keeps talking while he stands up and walks out. There's triumphalism in the air as he leaves. Everything I need to know about the appeal of fascism, I am learning from the Quiet Car.
10月18日，安静车厢的一幕。一个穿西装的男人开始打电话。坐在他后面的男人请他不要用手机。穿西装的男人说：“放松点，伙计。”后面那人说：“你放松点，遵守规则。”突然间乱套了。一个老人站起来说：“是的，遵守规则。我希望你尊重规则。”那个被电话吵到的人也加了进来：“尊重规则。没教养的人就是不尊重规则。”那一刻看起来真的可能要发生肢体冲突。但没有。打电话的男人边站起来边往外走，电话还没挂。他离开时空气中充满了胜利感。关于法西斯主义吸引力的所有知识，我都是从安静车厢里学到的。
January 24. I heard the loudest sound today. It was a man behind me, sighing. I had to change seats. After I change seats, someone in the row in front of my new seat gets on his cell phone. I exchange a glance with the man across the aisle, a glance that says, are you hearing what I'm hearing? We're trying to stay calm, no conductor in sight.
1月24日。今天我听到了最大的声音。是我后面的男人在叹气。我不得不换座位。我换完座位后，我新座位前排的人开始打电话。我和过道对面的人交换了一个眼神，那个眼神仿佛在说：“你听到了吗？”我们试图保持冷静，但周围连个列车员都没有。
The man on the phone says, "Hey Mark, how are you? Hold on, let me get my calendar." I stand up and lean over the seat and whisper, politely I think, "This is the Quiet Car. No cell phones." The man makes an apologetic face, and very pleasantly gets up and leaves. Other people in the car thank me with their eyes.
电话里那人说：“嘿，马克，你好吗？等一下，让我看看日程表。”我站起来，探过座位，我想我礼貌地低声说：“这里是安静车厢，禁止手机。”那人做出抱歉的表情，非常愉快地站起来离开了。车厢里的其他人用眼神向我致谢。
March 7. The Quiet Car is not bad in and of itself, but it encourages me to see myself as a Quiet Car person. It's tribal. I am quiet and good. Other people are loud and rude. I am the beleaguered hero of my own world. The woman sitting in the row ahead of me now, in her 50's wearing movie star shades and a cute hat, talking at a level I can hear, she's the other kind of person, self- loving, oblivious, spoiled.
3月7日。安静车厢本身没什么不好，但它鼓励我将自己视为“安静车厢人”。这是一种部落意识。我是安静且良好的，别人是吵闹且粗鲁的。我是自己世界里的受难英雄。现在坐在我前排的那个女人，50多岁，戴着电影明星般的遮阳镜，戴着可爱的帽子，用我能听到的音量说话，她是另一类人：自私、迟钝、被宠坏了。
I'm better than that, as though my Quiet Car demeanor is a gift I give the world rather than a choice I make for my own reasons. After all, wasn't I the one laughing too loudly a couple of times at dinner last night? Do I only like to be quiet in the places I want to be quiet?
我比那更好，就好像我安静车厢的举止是我给予世界的礼物，而不是我出于自身原因做的选择。毕竟，昨晚吃饭时我不也大声笑过几次吗？我难道只喜欢在我想安静的地方安静吗？
April 10. I've started putting in ear plugs in the Quiet Car. I know this is insane.
4月10日。我开始在安静车厢里戴上耳塞。我知道这很疯狂。
June 3. The train lost power, and we're sitting on the tracks not moving. Almost immediately, Quiet Car discipline broke down, as if the silence had been running on the same electrical system as the air conditioning. One woman got on speaker phone. Another woman started talking loudly into her phone about wine making.
6月3日。火车断电了，我们停在轨道上动弹不得。几乎立刻，安静车厢的纪律就崩溃了，好像宁静是和空调运行在同一个电力系统上似的。一个女人打开了外放通话。另一个女人开始大声对着手机谈论酿酒。
I heard someone clipping their nails, no joke. Not just one stray nail, all 10, one after another.
我听到有人在剪指甲，这不是开玩笑。不是一个指甲，是全部10个，一个接一个。
A man start having a loud, boring conversation to escape his boredom. "Yeah, we're stuck. Can you believe it? I don't know. I just called to let you guys know. So what are you up to?"
一个男人开始进行无聊的大声对话来逃避无聊：“是啊，我们被困住了。你敢信吗？我不知道。我只是打个电话告诉你们。你在做什么呢？”
I am sitting here shocked. I'm thinking loud thoughts at everyone around me. Is this all it takes for you to turn into savages? Where is your pride? Don't we stand for anything? We are Quiet Car people.
我坐在那里惊呆了。我对着周围的每个人发出大声的内心独白：这就是你们变成野蛮人所需要的吗？你们的尊严在哪？难道我们不坚持什么吗？我们可是“安静车厢人”。
January 18. The Quiet Car felt like a revolution at first, an overthrowing of a bad order. But then the revolution comes for you. I got off the train in Washington one night exhausted, seven hours in the Quiet Car up to New York and back in one day. And when I walked into the atrium of Union Station, there it was, a massive, inflatable colon, a large intestine with people walking in one end and out the other, part of a colon cancer awareness campaign.
1月18日。安静车厢起初感觉像是一场革命，一种对糟糕秩序的颠覆。但随后革命降临到了你身上。有一天晚上，我疲惫不堪地在华盛顿下了火车，一天之内在安静车厢往返纽约七个小时。当我走进联合车站中庭时，那东西就在那里——一个巨大的、充气的大肠，人们从一端走进去，从另一端走出来，这是结肠癌意识活动的一部分。
I stood there staring at it. When you're tired, anything can seem symbolic, especially something that's in your way, requiring a decision. Will you go around the giant colon and ignore what it has to say about the state of your health? Not how well you appear to the world, but the real truth of the matter. Or, will you step inside, and take a good look at all the foulness you've accumulated in your gut? I decided to go around it.
我站在那里盯着它。当你累的时候，任何东西看起来都有象征意义，特别是那种挡在你路前、要求你做决定的东西。你会绕过巨大的结肠，忽略它关于你健康状况的信息吗？不是你呈现给世界的假象，而是真正的真相。或者，你会走进去，好好看看你肠道里积累的所有污秽吗？我决定绕过它。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。
Well our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Seth Lind and P.J. Vogt. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好了，我们今天的节目由莉萨·波拉克和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作助理是塞斯·林德和P.J.沃格特。音乐咨询是杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站是 www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know I told him. I told him just the other day, why did you buy all of that Fannie Mae, and Freddie Mac, and Lehman Brothers? That was just a bad idea.
我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责管理WBEZ的项目。你知道我告诉过他。就在前几天我问他：“你为什么买那么多房利美、房地美和雷曼兄弟的股票？那简直是个坏主意。”
I know. I'm in the future also.
我知道。我也在未来。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到这里，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
公共广播国际台，PRI。